[Music]
you know somebody said with little
discipline you do little things with a
lot of discipline you do a lot of things
and with total discipline there is
nothing which you cannot do uh it
requires a lot of discipline i mean
obviously because you going to  move from
one world to the other from one culture
to the other from completely different
company you have jets organization
people are expecting you when you come
down from a plane after 14 hours flight
to be fresh and ready for them they're
not expecting a CEO  to come and say oh
my god this jet lag he cannot answer a
question they want you to be on the go
all the time so this requires a lot of
discipline you have to organize yourself
if if you know you're going to do this
job  and you accept the job you have to
organize yourself in order to do it it's
stough but there is a solution there is
is a solution for it but it requires a
lot of choices personal choices there
are lot of things you cannot do you know
there are  lot of things you can do but
going to do them within a certain order
but particularly with a lot with a lot
of
[Music]
discipline